Mì bố thân chính, các phải đoàn của Mỹ và Trung Quốc đã nhóm họ gặp đại trụ đô ma truit của tế bà nhà,
tiến hành đối thoại về các bà đề kinh tế và thương mạnh.
Đây là của họ bệnh thứ tư chỉ trong bỏng bố tháng qua,
dựa 2 niềm kinh tế là nhất thế giới,
nhằm thào gỡ những vương mắc,
xuống quan chính sách thời quan của tổ thống Mỹ đô năng trăm.
Dẫn đầu phá đoàn Mỹ tham gia đàn phán là bộ trưởng tại chính Scott Benzain,
trong khi giận đầu phải đoàn Trung Quốc là phó thu tưởng hà là phóng.
Theo một quan trức chính phủ Mỹ,
cũng đang phá lần này tập trung thảo lận xung quan các vấn đề về thời quan
phóng đồng của mặt sầu tích tóc và các vấn đề kinh tế khác.
Trước đó, một thương mại Trung Quốc ngày 12h,
hai bên sẽ thảo lần về các vấn đề như biển pháp thời quan đơn xương của Mỹ.
Việc á dụng các biển pháp kiểm soát sức khẩu và vấn đề liên quan đến hả động của tích tóc tại Mỹ.
Một thương mại Trung Quốc kêu gọi Mỹ giải quyết vấn đề liên quan tích tóc,
thông qua đối thoại trên cơ sở tôn trọng lần nhau và tham vận mình đăng.
Theo những chiến quyền của tổng thống Mỹ đồ năng trăm đăng yêu cầu cũng tìa bài đàn sử dụng sẽ hiểu của tích tóc.
Phải bán nên tạo này trong người mua không phải người Trung Quốc,
với hạn chóc trước là mì bài hàng chiến,
nếu không muốn bị cầm tại Mỹ.